there's an island in the background
somewhere and it would it's like what's
it called no man for no man's simular
anyway it's amazing we really wanted to
go there but we can't because it's fully
booked so instead we're gonna go to the
Isle of Wight we were gonna drive there
but we've been told in this coffee shop
that we can hover there on a hover car I
can't imagine how this is gonna go but
let's go and see if we can hover to the
Isle of Wight Isle of Man let's see what
we've just seen the ship pros of going
on the ferry Isle of Wight is what we're
like are with us but pros of the
hovering is its it's cool and it's
instant like Samuel has just gone into
the hover travel shop that we've just
come across and he's gonna see if we can
hop over to get to the Isle of Wight
interest okay there we go we're hovering
over in ten minutes time to the island
walk ten minutes time let's go baby
we're now just literally getting our
overnight stuff - then jump on the hover
how long how long does it take there is
no way I literally thought that it was
because it was over I thought it was
like a zip wire or something but it
really is about I think
the captain raised the alarm over the
public address so like 15 minutes ago
we'll start having a copy and now we're
here on other boats which is going so
fast
so we've just arrived at the island
white in mapping right there which took
literally ten minutes for us to get
right from Portsmouth what's with the ax
to the olive white how you feelin Monday
everything just works when you
spontaneous do you recommend oh yeah if
we do try to plan this and book the
hover boat and Butler this book it would
have probably been a nightmare just
turning up with no plan it doesn't
matter what happens and everything just
seems to work out and babe I can see an
ice rink and a bowling alley right for
the window how are you feeling bad yeah
and right now there's a reason that
Amanda is on the grass because she's
scared of the ducks so we're gonna make
him underwater if there's a reason why
no one else is walking on this path it's
cuz the Ducks were the big one before
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you make that sound yeah they were
not moving for anyone and this is really
my dream come true because I love water
so we have the lake a private swimming
pool and then to say oh my goodness I'm
in heaven just got back and now we are
to drive down the coast till we get to
Dorset where we've booked a nice full
body massage so looking forward to that
and we have to keep stopping for Amanda
to take pictures of the beautiful
scenery is nice there to be fair just
arrived at our hotel that time to go for
a nice massage and spa really nice place
this absolutely little dead room is
fantastic great bath just ordering
desserts after the nicest or most
organic beautiful meal I've probably
ever had
andis now deciding what to have
and we're both suffering after our
massage she was like ruthless ninja
massage lady but it's okay this is what
you see when you step out of our room
I'm just waiting on Samuel literally on
the edge of the ocean okay we haven't
taken a bus or a train or any of the
normal ways of public transport but we
have taken all the adventurous styles of
public transport how do you like this
way of traveling is a lot better than
the car or what may be another car
versus those kissing when it gets higher
I don't really like to look ducks and
Marie's gonna fight when we first got on
I was so scared
a lot of people say that all the workers
throw rubbish in England but the problem
is it's often quite nice but most people
are just at work so they miss it so if
you go to work at 9:00 then you finish
at 6:00 you and you would miss this and
right now like literally I'm getting
sunburned even even madness getting
sunburned my handsome man oh now we're
on the river time very fast boat ride I
don't think we're going to end up with
the London Eye
here we go
I can feel the water on my check oh yeah
just be treated to a fantastic lunch for
my by my buddy Marcus de Maria she's a
lot of people chase the money and it's
just my opinion but I think it's the
wrong reason you gotta have a mission
gotta have a purpose I mean I was just
talking to Samuel about yesterday we
were at the marathon we were supporting
at London Marathon we were supporting
and shout-out to you we would everybody
come on like this I'm so inspired by all
of these people and I've decided I'm
asking and we've got this out this is
live right I've asked Sam to do the
marathon with me my number one tip and
there's a lot but my number one tip is
know your reason why know your purpose
know your mission in life
[Music]